Health Systems have been severely
disrupted with millions of people
missing out on Essential Health services
including life-saving vaccinations for
children
but copied 19 has been so much more than
a Health crisis
it has codes severe economic upheaval
erasing trillions from GDP disrupting
trouble and tread
shattering businesses and plunging
Millions into poverty
it has caused severe social upheaval
with borders closed movement restricted
schools shut and millions of people
experiencing loneliness isolation
anxiety
and depression
covid-19 has exposed an exacerbated
political fault lines
within and between nations
it has eroded trust between people
governments and institutions
fueled by a torrent of Miss and
disinformation
and it has laid bare the Searing
inequalities of our world
with the poorest and most vulnerable
communities the hardest hit
and the last to receive access to
vaccines and other tools
for more than a year
the pandemic has been on a downward
trend
with population immunity increasing from
vaccination and infection
mortality decreasing and the pressure on
Health Systems easy
this trend has allowed most countries to
return to Life As We Knew It Before
kovid 19.
for the past year
the emergency committee and who have
been analyzing the data carefully and
considering when the time would be right
to lower the level of alarm
yesterday
the emergency committee met for the 15th
time and recommended to me that I
declare an end to the public health
emergency of international concern
I have accepted that advice
it's therefore with great hope that I
declare covid-19 over as a global Health
Emergency
however
that does not mean covid-19 is over as a
global Health threat
last week covid-19 claimed live every
three minutes
and that's just the this we know about
as we speak thousands of people around
the world are fighting for their lives
in intensive care units
and millions more continue to live with
the debilitating effects of postcovid 19
condition
this virus is here to stay
it's still killing
and it's still changing
the risk remains of a new of new
variants emerging that cause new surges
in cases and does
the worst thing any country could do now
is to use this news as a reason to let
down its God
to dismantle the systems it has built
or to send the message to its people
that covid-19 is nothing to worry about
what this news means is that it's time
for countries to transition from
emergency mode to managing copied 19
alongside other infectious diseases
I emphasize that this is not a snap
decision
it's a decision that has been considered
carefully for some time
plan for and met on the basis of a
careful analysis of the data
if need be I will not hesitate to
convince another emergency committee
should covid-19 once again put our world
in peril
while this emergency committee will now
seize its work
it has sent a clear message that
countries must not cease theirs
on the committee's advice I have decided
to use a provision in the international
Health regulations that has never been
used before
to establish a Review Committee to
develop long-term standing
recommendations for countries on how to
manage covid-19 on an ongoing basis
in addition
who this week published the fourth
edition of the global strategic
preparedness and response plan for covet
19.
which outlines critical actions for
countries in five core areas
collaborative surveillance Community
protection safe and scalable care access
to counter measures and emergency
coordination
for more than three years
the experts on the emergency committee
have devoted their time
their experience
and their expertise
not just to advise me on whether
covid-19 continues to represent a global
health emergency but to also advise on
recommendations for countries
I would like to express my deep
gratitude to all the members of the
emergency committee for their thoughtful
consideration and wise advice
I thank specially Professor Didier USA
for his leadership as chair over the
past three years
he has led the committee with a calm
demoner
and a steady hand through turbulent
times
I also wish to thank the incredible
people who I have the privilege to call
my colleagues
for more than three years
the people of who have labored day and
night
under intense pressure
and intense scrutiny
they have brought together partners and
experts from around the world to
generate evidence
study and translate into it into
guidance and actions for the world
in countries around the world who has
worked closely with governments to
translate that guidance into policies
and actions to save lives
my colleagues have worked tirelessly to
get vaccines and other supplies to more
people faster
and they have countered Miss and
disinformation with accurate and
reliable information
I do not have the words to express my
gratitude to everyone around the world
who like me is proud to be who
at one level
this is a moment for celebration
we have arrived at this moment thanks to
the incredible skill and selfless
dedication of Health and Care workers
around the world
the innovation of vaccine researchers
and Developers
the tough decisions governments have had
to make in the face of changing evidence
and the sacrifices that all of us have
met as individuals families and
communities to keep ourselves and each
other safe
at another level
this is a moment for reflection
covid-19 has left
and continues to live
deep scars on our world
those cars must serve as a permanent
reminder of the potential for new
viruses to emerge
with devastating consequences
as a global community
the suffering we have endured
the painful lessons we have learned
the Investments we have made and the
capacities we have built must not go to
West
we owe it to those we have lost to
leverage those Investments
to build on those capacities
to learn those lessons and to transform
that suffering into meaningful and
Lasting change
one of the greatest tragedies of kobit
19 is that it didn't have to be this way
we have the tools and the Technologies
to prepare for pandemics better
to detect them earlier
to respond to them faster
and to mitigate their impact
but globally a lack of coordination a
lack of equity and the lack of
solidarity meant that those tools were
not used as effectively as they could
have been
lives were lost that should not have
been
we must promise ourselves
and our children and grandchildren that
we will never make those mistakes again
that's what the pandemic Accord and the
amendments to the international Health
regulations that countries are now
negotiating are about
a commitment to Future Generations that
we will not go back to the old cycle of
panic and neglect that left our world
vulnerable
but move forward with a shared
commitment
to meet share threats
with a shared response
in 1948
the nations of the world came together
in the aftermath of the bloodiest war in
history to commit working together for a
healthier world
recognizing that diseases have no regard
for the lines humans draw on maps
they forged an agreement a treaty the
constitution of the World Health
Organization
three-quarters of a century later
nations are once again coming together
to forge an agreement to ensure we never
repeat the same mistakes again
if we don't make this change
then who will
this is the right generation to make
those changes
and if we don't make them now
then when
like countries
communities
and public health institutions around
the world
who has learned an enormous amount from
this pandemic
kovid has changed our world
and it has changed us
that's the way it should be
if we all go back to how things were
before covid-19
we will have failed to learn our lessons
and we will have failed future
Generations
this experience must change us all for
the better
it must make us more determined to
fulfill the vision that Nations had when
they found the who in 1948
the highest
possible standard of help for all people
as I said earlier
throughout this process
Professor Didier USA has done an
outstanding job for leading the
emergency committee
and he's with us today
Professor USA thank you so much for your
leadership over the past three years
and you have the floor
thank you very much Dr Ted Rose thank
you for those kind words
dear colleagues ladies and gentlemen
francophone
in January
2022 more than one year ago
during the 10th meeting of the emergency
committee for kovit 19. its members
suggested to who that it was necessary
to prepare for the moment when the
qualification of the kovin 19 event
would change
upon which criteria
with which precautions
with which communication messages
after a 16 months of reflection work and
discussion with who Secretariat
easy members considered yesterday that
time had arrived for the transition from
the public health emergency of
international concern the fake status
which qualified the event under the ihr
to another approach of the event taking
into account the other possibilities
offered by the international Health
regulations
why now
there are three reasons why now
firstly because the main criteria for
such
a transition are now met
it is true that the virus continues to
circulate in every country and that the
pandemic is not over
it is true that there are many
uncertainties particularly regarding the
evolution of the virus
it is true also that there are big gaps
in surveillance reporting and Healthcare
particularly in the most vulnerable
countries
hi Val however the situation has
markedly improved
with less mortality and an increased
immunity against the virus
immunity which is vaccine induced or
naturally induced and a better access to
Diagnostics vaccines and treatment
why now the second reason is because it
is time to change the tool
the tool which is fake is a tool offered
by the ihr has played its role within
which consists in placing forward an
imperative the emergency to generate
mobilization and reaction
however this tool should not be overused
because it is not adapted to evens which
become Subacute or chronic
which is the case presently with the
kovin 19 epidemic
of course if necessary and Dr terros
said it because of the emergence of a
highly pathogenic mutant it will be
possible to return to the fake situation
that it is better now to look in the ihr
toolbox for a better more adapted
instrument
this instrument and its use was
suggested yesterday to the director
general of who it is to go for standing
recommendations rather than just
temporary recommendations
such standing recommendations will allow
to better integrate risk assessment and
risk management concerning covid-19 in
the broader framework of pandemic
preparedness and response
it will also allow to reinforce the link
between surveillance prevention and
treatment of covid-19 and the strong
system established since many years
about influenza viruses in animals and
humans
EC members are aware that the production
of standing recommendations will take a
few months because it requires the
constitution of a specific Review
Committee this is why during this
interim few month period EC members
suggested to the DG to continue produce
temporary recommendation
in order to avoid a gap in the vigilance
and the reaction to South covid II as
you understand EC members suggested a
belt and shoulder approach because they
remain suspicious concerning the
deleterious potentialities of saskovit
II
an example of this belt and shoulder
approach was also to make sure that the
transition from the fake status would
not have an impact on access to vaccines
because of a change in the regulatory
environment
why now the third reason is that because
EC members are convinced that it is
possible for who to produce messages
indicating to member states and to the
public that transitioned from the fake
status to another status of the event is
not a signal to lower the guard on the
contrary that it is a strong signal to
go for a better order of higher scale
aiming at sustainability and with the
ambition to take lessons and to
reinforce the protection against
emerging viruses with pandemic potential
to conclude first I wish to warmly thank
easy members and the colleague from The
Who
secretaryat for these three more three
more than three years of work and I
shall summarize the position expressed
by the emergency Committee in one
sentence after more than three years now
is the time to confront covid-19
pandemic which has caused so much
suffering with new tools and new
Ambitions one of them being also to
prepare for future pandemics thank you
questions from journalists if you want
to ask a question raise your hand using
the icon raise your hand and unmute
yourself
um to start where they would like to
invite Helen branswell from start to ask
the first question Helen can you hear me
Helen
thank you fidela
um
I wanted to ask how the world should
interpret this uh announcement I think
many of us mistook the DG's statement on
March 11th of 2020 to mean that the who
had declared a pandemic I've since
learned who does not declare pandemics
and it will not declare an end to the
pandemic but many people will likely see
this announcement as an end to the
pandemic is the pandemic over if it's
not how and when will we know that it is
over thank you
thank you Helen Dr Ryan
thanks
Helen um
the uh I think what is clear from the
statements today from both Dr Tedros and
Professor Hussein
um that the the public health emergency
of international concern has been
terminated which means from the
perspective of the World Health
Organization uh the global Public Health
Emergency has ended but there is as Dr
Taylor said there's still a public
health threat out there and we all see
that every day in terms of the evolution
of this virus in terms of its Global
presence its continued Evolution and
continued vulnerabilities in our
communities both societal
vulnerabilities age vulnerabilities
protections vulnerabilities and many
other things so we fully expect that
this virus will continue to transmit and
this is the history of pandemics if we
look at it took decades for the final
throws of the pandemic virus of 1918 to
disappear it reverberates to the system
and it's an echo in the system that you
see and it just bounces around until we
reach a point in most cases pandemics
truly end when the next pandemic begins
I know that's a a terrible thought but
that is the history of pandemics uh
they're also as you said Helen some
confusion we describe many things as
pandemics we describe a pandemic of
obesity the pandemic of gun violence the
many different things that are not very
well described uh it's a very difficult
thing to describe I've said before that
it comes from the Greek pan Demas Demas
meaning the people pan meaning all
pandemos pandemic all of the people any
virus that threatens all of the people
of the world at any one time can be
considered to be a pandemic the question
remains does that virus continue to
threaten all human beings yes it does
but as Professor Hussein said the
committee it continues to threaten at a
much lower level of impact at a much
more level of lower level of tragedy a
much lower level of death a much lower
level of hospitalization so we've got
control over the virus by applying the
science by applying the lessons that we
have learned hard-won lessons of this
pandemic so the virus as I said will
continue to to transmission
and we'll continue to transmit for a
very long time but the most important I
think fact for today is that the global
Public Health Emergency as defined in
the ihr is over
the I think Professor Hussein's comments
are particularly important to saying we
now need to move on to the next phase
referred to that the battle is not over
we still have weaknesses and those
weaknesses that we still have in our
system will be exposed by this virus or
another virus and it needs to be fixed
our ability to prepare the equity in our
systems the our ability to innovate uh
the strength of our health systems and
not just the strength of our Public
Health Emergency Response systems but
the inherent strength of our health
systems that was mentioned our EPI and
immunization programs have been weakened
access to cancer therapy has been
weakened many other parts of our health
system have been have been threatened
and have been made vulnerable even more
vulnerable by by covert so the um
covert has ended as an emergency from a
Global Perspective but covert is still
an emergency for a family who have a
loved one who contracts covert today and
needs to go to hospital that is still an
emergency that's an emergency for a
family it's an emergency for a community
but we can move on now in terms of that
Miriam you may have some more um more
comments to make but uh I think there
will not be a point where who comes
along and says the pandemic is over the
reality is this virus will continue to
spread the good news is the global
Health Emergency is over
foreign thanks Mike and thanks Helen for
this question
um it's a poignant one because as you
say people equate the two and as the DG
said very clearly
um the emergency phase of This Global
crisis that we have all been facing for
three and a half years is over but kovid
is here to stay and we have to learn to
manage this better in Integrated Systems
because the virus isn't going anywhere
we've been thinking a lot about this
over the last several days and and how
to describe this and make it
understandable or more clear as clear as
we possibly can and one of the things
we've tried to do in three over three
and a half years is to complicate these
complicated messages
um and I think of it like an earthquake
you know I think of this whole situation
like a massive earthquake that we've all
experienced at the same time and we have
had aftershocks that have been
tremendous over the course of the last
several years and the foundation in
which we live the buildings that we live
in are fractured have crumbled the
people that work in those buildings have
died the people have been crushed by
overwhelming stress and incredible
responsibility and we've had many
aftershocks over the course of the last
year
the challenge we Face going forward is
that this virus is evolving there are
thousands of people dying every week
there are hundreds of thousands of
people who are in hospital there are
millions of people who are infected
every week so we have to not take our
eye off the ball and while we're not in
the crisis mode we can't let our guard
down and the DG was very clear about
this today and he has been very clear
about this for some time as he said this
is not a snap decision this is a
decision and a transition that has been
happening for some time so we will be
living with this virus in fact one of
our colleagues said the other day that
we will actually be able to reflect
historically to say when the pandemic
could be declared over or could be over
and I shouldn't have said that because
we don't declare pandemics to begin or
to declare pandemics as over
epidemiologically this virus will
continue to cause waves what we are
hopeful of is that we have the tools in
place to ensure that the future waves do
not result in more severe disease don't
result in waves of death and we can do
that with the tools we have at hand we
just need to make sure that we are
tracking the virus because it will
continue to evolve
so thanks very much for that question
we'll do our best to continue to explain
this but as we've said the crisis phase
the emergency phase is over but covid is
not
foreign
I would like to invite Jeremy launch
from Radio France International to ask
the next question Jeremy
thank you Father I would like to ask my
question in French for Mr division uh
[Music]
a
freudirect
should have said it in English I just
wanted to respond to the questions about
the level of majority in the emergency
committee it was almost consensual
decision
from the committee and the two or three
we were which were a bit hesitant but
this option rallied the consensus
merci Professor USA now I would like to
invite Tomo de Gucci from Kyoto news to
ask the next question Tomo
hi uh can you hear me
yes please go ahead
thank you my question goes to Dr Tedros
uh how concerned are you about the
negative effect of terminating State
before concluding the negotiation on a
new pandemic Accord
wouldn't it undermine the urgency of
establishing a new Accord and lead to
losing the momentum of negotiation thank
you
foreign
and thank you for reflecting on the
importance of the of the Accord
um it's really really important that the
world and the world leaders move on to
creating an architecture within which we
will all be safer uh having a mechanism
to govern that having a set of rules
having having it an accord an agreement
a solemn agreement amongst member states
that we will not forget as Dr kedro said
that we will remember the lessons but
normally remember we will apply them and
we will apply them together and we will
apply them in solidarity and we will
apply them or in a way in which all
nations have a say all nations have a
stake in that future agreement for how
we're going to prepare together respond
together protect together
um this is truly important but I don't I
don't actually believe that this will
have a negative effect I think this adds
urgency to the discussions on the Accord
because we cannot as the professor
Hussein says continue to use emergency
instruments to manage our Collective
response to these threats we have to put
in place the measures we have to put in
place the structures we have to put in
place the workforce we have to build a
health system that can actually deal
with multiple different crises we're not
just facing a world of epidemics we have
climate stress we have weaknesses in our
health system economic stresses our
health systems need to be stronger our
Public Health Systems need to be
stronger our integration multi-sectoral
approach to emerging threats needs to be
stronger
Professor Hussein outlined that the the
ihr and the emergency committee
mechanism and the mechanism of declaring
Public Health emergencies is an
emergency instrument it is designed to
create consensus around common threats
and agree on common ways forward that is
the process of the temporary
recommendations it is designed to be
independent way of advising the director
General on how to manage those threats
but it is not an instrument for managing
the long-term strategic threat that we
face which is a growing frequency and
intensity of epidemics with pandemic
potential it is a massive responsibility
for the world leaders to come together
heads of state Ministers of Health other
ministers and Civil Society to agree on
a new solemn a solemn agreement for how
we move forward together on this planet
we all inhabit this planet together
tedra said in his speech the viruses do
not respect the lines we draw on maps
which I think is very very profound
description of the common threat we Face
leaving aside those lines on maps our
members need our member states and the
leaders of Our member states have to
come together we hope and agree on what
the future will look like and make that
promise to Future Generations as Dr
tedro said I don't know if you want to
supplement you
I think Mike had said it all I don't
think it will have a negative impact on
the negotiation
of the pandemic Accord
um
as
you know we have all been in this
pandemic now
um
the lessons we have learned should
actually dictate
the need for for pandemic Accord
um
the world was not well prepared when
this pandemic hit
and with the pandemic Accord we can be
prepared better
and the pandemic Accord should be based
on the lessons learned so if there is
real commitment not to make the same
mistakes again
the presence of an emergency fake or not
doesn't matter because for the last
three years we have already learned the
lessons
so I I believe this generation has
especially the obligation because it has
experienced firsthand what unprecedented
pandemic means
and that will be enough to drive the
negotiations forward and have a good
outcome by May 2024 that's when we're
expecting to have the the Accord and
that Accord in terms of content that
really encompasses all the lessons
learned from from this pandemic
and making sure that you know In Our
Lifetime and in the coming generation
the same thing or same mistake is not
repeated
so I I don't see the negative impact on
on the negotiation
of the pandemic Accord thank you and
fedila back to you
thank you Dr Tedros I would like now to
invite Kai kappersmith from science to
ask the next question Kai can you hear
me
yes thanks
two really brief ones if I may so first
of all tedro said that um he had invoked
a provision in the ihr that hasn't been
used before to establish a Review
Committee I'd be curious to hear a
little bit more about you know who's
going to be on that what's the timeline
um what exactly does he hope uh to
achieve with it and then I'm just
curious what you know in weighing this
decision
um what Professor Didier Hussein and
others felt was the biggest risk of this
what what weight on their minds the most
as they as they made this decision
thank you Kai we will start with Dr Ryan
yeah very beautiful hand over the karma
and then to Diddy on the uh the issue of
what the committee's deliberations were
and thank you Kai uh for the question
um the uh Karma will explain the the the
the the the the detail of what the
procedures that are available to us put
together I want to emphasize that we've
issued a strategic preparedness and
response plan yesterday who has already
laid out for the world but the key
elements of action that are needed by
governments across collaborative
surveillance Community protection safe
scalable clinical care access to
countermeasures and emergency
coordination the the process associated
with the emergency committee would be
the the generation of standing
recommendations which would last for a
much longer time this Karma will give
the the timing of those and would be
recommendations aimed at Broad
long-standing recommendations to member
states about the continued control of
covert and its integration actually into
wider control measures or wider
strategic areas Carmen
thank you Mike and thank you for the
question
um the provision that Professor Hussein
referred to is actually
um the article 50 for those who are
actually familiar with the ihr article
50 of the ihr who sets out the mandates
of a Review Committee and it covers
three elements
um this Review Committee in general one
is to provide advice on the director
General on um amendments to the ihr and
you may be aware that such a Review
Committee has just
completed their work in early January
this year in relation to the Amendments
proposed to the ihr
um the second Mandate of such a review
committee is to provide advice to the
director general or make technical
recommendations on the functioning of
the ihr and you are aware that a Review
Committee on the functioning of the ihr
during kovi 19 also has
been convened in 2021 2022 and the third
element of that mandate for a Review
Committee is exactly this one to provide
the advice to the director General
understanding recommendations indeed
this has not been used before the
previous Review Committee only addressed
the two elements of that mandate
that I mentioned before
um on the issue of composition of the
Review Committee
um the ihr gives the um the details of
how this committee should be um selected
and basically uh the members will come
from the roster of experts established
under the ihr
um and the composition will um
be based on the principles of Equitable
geographical representation gender
balance uh balance of experts from
developed and developing countries as
well as representative of different um
diversity of scientific opinion and
approaches
um the functioning of this committee
will follow the same rules and and the
procedures of any expert advisory body
in the same way that the emergency
committee follows those rules and the
reports will be provided to the director
General that committee that Review
Committee will also have the possibility
of uh hearing uh um positions from
Member States from State parties to the
ihr actually and from other
representative of un organizations uh
and non-state actors the issue and
substanding recommendations as Mike was
saying these standing recommendations
are like temp recommendations
non-binding advice issued under the
legal framework of the ihr but who which
do not have to be reviewed every three
months like the temporary
recommendations they are provided for
the management of events of the longer
uh term and would actually reflect
the the needs that countries face now in
this transition process
lastly the standing recommendations uh
once issued by the director General two
State parties will also have to be
submitted to the health assembly of the
subsequent Health assembly for its
considerations but not for its approval
thank you Father I hope it answers the
question
thank you Professor thank you thank you
very much well this question is um is
important because of course the
transition from one status to another is
always a risky a risky moment I can
refer for example to the hermit crab
when he has to Transit from one shell to
another is in a difficult situation and
the EC members were confronted this to
this question
the risks which were identified for risk
four main risks were identified the
first one is to be caught by surprise by
the emergence of a of a more pathogenic
mutant and of course the the response to
this risk is to reinstate of course for
the director General a new emergency
committee to get provide response
adapted to this new new event the other
risks were identified as a communication
risks
that is a misinterpretation
leading to lowering the God and this was
discussed previously by Dr terros and by
Mike Ryan another risk which was
identified was the regulatory risk that
is will this change lead to some
difficulties in access to vaccines
because of the modification of the legal
environment
and the fourth risk which was identified
was a moment of vacuum in the transition
from science to to to decision uh by
through expertise so the the the
analyzes the balance of the benefits and
risks which was made by the emergency
committee was to conclude that it was
important to be realistic considering
the situation and also to to explore the
potential which has which is offered by
new tools which were mentioned that is
standing recommendation and so the this
is the the the response which were
brought to this risk how to mitigate the
communication risk and I think the
meeting today is extremely important
because the messages you will transfer
will be a key to the to the behavior of
the member states and the public with
regard to the covid-19 and also the all
the measures which I've mentioned
mentioned to to mitigate the risks
identified thank you
merci Professor USA I would like now to
invite uh Bianca Rosier from TV Global
Brazil to ask the next question Bianca
you have the floor
thank you
hi fadella can you hear me
very well
go ahead thanks a lot thanks a lot yeah
we have been waiting for this day for a
long time I'm happy to see you together
now for this announcement
um I think uh yeah you talked about
mistakes and looking behind
how do you evaluate the Brazilian
response
um what Brazil did that no country
should repeat in case we have or when we
have another Health Emergency and I take
this opportunity to also make a second
question I believe you are aware of a
huge scandal in Brazil this week
and and I would love if Dr tedres could
um
talk about that just to explain there is
an investigation about the suspected
efforts to fake covid-19 vaccination
records from the former president Jay
bolsonaro in a way that he could travel
to the United States in case you don't
want Dr tedris to comment specifically
on that journal generally speaking could
you please explain how dangerous it is
to fake a vaccination certificate I
imagine it put people at risk so how
what are the risks thanks a lot thank
you Bianca Dr venkarkov we'll take the
first question and I believe we
responded by email to your second
question thank you Bianca yes thank you
Bianca um you know you ask a very also a
very good question and I think over the
last three and a half years we are
always looking at ways in which every
single one of us on the planet could do
better
um you know I was recently giving a talk
and asking you know do we remember do
you remember the beginning of this when
we knew so little and we were acting on
as much information as we could get our
hands on to make the best decisions
possible and there have been many
recommendations that have been provided
over the last three and a half years and
as a learning organization we are
constantly applying those I look you
know as the DG said today we are sitting
here hopeful and humble looking forward
looking forward to what needs to be done
looking forward to what remains to be
done to ensure that we don't lose the
momentum over the last three and a half
years that we don't lose the gains that
have been made across all of the pillars
of response of surveillance of expanded
lab capacity of incredible increases in
genomic sequencing on better clinical
Care on rapid development of scientific
advancements of collaborations and all
that and we rely on our member states
and the scientists and public health
professionals in all those countries and
as you've heard me say before in this
forum the researchers and scientists
that we've worked with in Brazil have
been absolutely outstanding before this
pandemic during this pandemic and this
will continue as the pandemic continues
and as the next epidemic unfolds but I
think also as we look to the past we
also need to be respectful and humbled
of what has happened
and I fortunately have visited Brazil a
few times in the last couple of years
and went to manaus
and visited the health care facilities
the hospitals the front line workers who
cared for so many people who died
and every single one of the people that
I met lost someone
and they were back at it every single
day to do better and that's what we're
up here to do to do better
and I think of what we shouldn't forget
while being hopeful looking to the
future we can't forget
the amount of death that has happened as
the DG put it it didn't have to be this
way
and it doesn't have to be this way again
so we can't forget the images of the
hospitals
of the icus filled to capacity
of the images of of
medical gloves filled with warm water
they're holding the hands of our loved
ones who died
with health care workers who ensured
that they didn't die alone
we can't forget those fire pyres we
can't forget the graves that were dug
I won't forget them none of us up here
will forget them and that drives us
every single day to do better and to do
more so while I am hopeful and I and I
really am I'm quite emotional
because there's more we need to do
so thank you for asking these questions
and for being part of this journey with
us and Reporting accurately And Timely
and conveying difficult information
because it has been difficult and it
will continue to be difficult because
there is more work to do so hopeful to
the Future
respectful of the past constantly
learning lessons and that is not
something that's going to change so
thanks for the question
um
um certainly right now as we enter this
next year or two
Brazilian diplomats Brazilian Health
leaders are intimately and prominently
involved in the negotiation of pandemic
Accord in the negotiations around ihr
revision uh
the re the the Pan American Health
Organization has uh
elected a fine Brazilian as its lead and
as Maria said Brazilian science
Brazilian vaccine Innovation Brazilian
innovation in in in surveillance I I met
a couple of weeks ago with the head of
the health emergency section of the
ministry of healthcare with with Dr Abdi
and I was so impressed to learn just how
much the Brazilian system at State and
at National level is evolving and it's
becoming a real
a real leading life in the Americas and
globally an anchor for Global Innovation
and anchor for Global public health so
we're really really pleased to see that
we're really pleased to see that
leadership emerging we're really pleased
to see Brazil engaging with the world
and we're really pleased to see both
scientific and diplomatic leadership
having a major impact on the future of
Public Health and public health security
thank you next question is for
Christopher's Kristoff
Christoph we cannot really hear you can
you speak out please
I guess
um
Kristoff
I will come back to you because we
cannot hear you at all so let's
um
move now to the next journalist from
nature
it's a Paul let me just Paul adeju Paul
can you hear me
Paul yes yes I can hear you thank you
very much so my question asked with
um the implication of this declaration
on the response in Africa
waste study inequality and vaccine
nationalism that's where the Hallmarks
for the response that eventually slowed
uh African countries in responding
um how do you expect this declaration uh
to impact the gains made and considering
the fact that several of the Milestones
have not been achieved in many African
countries thank you very much
okay yeah Kate O'Brien will take this
question
um it was a really broad question but
I'll I'll address it from the
perspective of uh of certainly the
vaccine component of this what's really
important about uh the declaring the
standing down of the public health
emergency is the vaccine effort does not
end here
what is extremely important is to know
first of all that the authorization of
the vaccines continues there is work to
be done to move the authorizations of
vaccines into the sort of more regular
form of authorization but all vaccines
that have been authorized continue to
hold that status for the time being the
second thing is that there's a full
commitment to continue to support
countries in their ambition to broaden
out the coverage of vaccination
especially for those groups who most
need vaccines as has been described we
continue to have cases and deaths and
the work isn't over coverage of those
individuals who are at high risk of
serious illness and of death is still
far too low in so many countries around
Africa and in other parts of the world
and especially with the booster dose
which is really important for protection
against that severe end of the spectrum
I think the third thing to say is that
there is a commitment Kovacs is
continuing to be in operation through
the rest of this year and there will be
decisions made about the continuation of
provision of vaccine for uh the
countries that have benefited from the
vaccine Supply through Kovacs those
those discussions and decisions are
ongoing through gavi uh through the gavi
Alliance and we're really looking
forward to making those decisions uh as
to assure that there continues to be a
vaccine that's available
for all people who still need that
protection and I think what we want to
emphasize so much is that the vaccines
are working and it is in in large part
not only the vaccines all of the efforts
and measures that have been taken but
the vaccines have played a really
important role in protecting populations
so that even when people get infected
the seriousness of the illness the risk
of death has
um really been addressed through the
through vaccination of individuals and
so we want to emphasize as has been said
so many times by Maria by the director
General by Mike
um that the work is not over by making
this announcement the work actually
continues and we have been planning for
um the day when this day would come that
we would be transitioning into this next
phase and the work remains essential and
it remains essential for the life-saving
nature of the vaccines
perhaps Maria wants to add a couple of
other things thank you
sorry so yes no just a couple of other
points to add on top of what Kate has
said we know that the African continent
has not been spared from covet 19.
um and what people individuals
governments Labs across the continent
health workers have done has really been
tremendous and has expanded in
capacities
and just to highlight on the testing
side you know we had countries in Africa
Somalia had no PCR testing capacity
before this pandemic and now have Labs
across the country can do sequencing we
have had countries across the continent
who have led on the detection of
variants and variants of concern
reporting these
immediately to who with the technical
Advisory Group for virus Evolution so
that we could take rapid action and
these are incredible scientists across
South Africa I shouldn't name some
countries because I will inevitably
leave some out that shouldn't be left
out but the expansion and capacity for
Laboratory Testing for sequencing but
also in clinical care and access to
Medical oxygen the amount of work that
has been done to expand access to and
use of sustainable medical oxygen across
the continent has grown the challenge
right now is to sustain and maintain
this because it's not only important for
covet 19. it's important for other
diseases that are in circulation
um and so that's what we are working on
with all of our member States including
across Africa and just lastly just to
mention the engagement of communities of
individuals of Youth across the
continent have remained absolutely
essential in listening because as you've
heard us say many times before outbreaks
begin and end in communities and with
the engagement of individuals and most
importantly listening to
empowering them finding the solutions to
be able to implement
life-saving interventions is is what it
continues to be necessary so there's a
lot of work that has been done that
needs to continue the challenge now as
many questions have pointed out is
really how do we keep up this momentum
how do we sustain this and as the DG
said the worst thing to do right now is
to dismantle systems is to stop
because what we are doing for covet is
important for covid but it's important
for pandemic prevention preparedness
Readiness and response as we go forward
so everything that is is has been
invested in is important for now and for
the future
thank you I would like to call once
again on Christoph from ifp Christoph
can you hear me
yes I can hear you can you hear me now
yeah
excellent thank you I'm really sorry
about that after three years you would
think I can use the zoom call anyway
thank you very much for taking my
question
um
two things is just maybe a clarification
on the 20 million dead Dr Tedros alluded
to uh if you could just clarify exactly
how you condos because it's as we know
quite far away from the official count
and then second uh and and Dr wankerkov
started sharing with us uh what may be
marked our most or what you remember
most in this last three years I was
wondering if maybe Dr Ted was too would
would give what is the image of that
you're going to uh to keep in your mind
from from this period that has been
not closed as you made it very clear but
at least uh the the worst part is seems
to be behind us for now
thank you
so I could start and then the question
was to Dr tedra so I will let him answer
I think on the excess mortality this is
these are estimates
um we have reported deaths to who and as
of
um a few days ago this was more than 6.9
million reported deaths and we've
undertaken uh an estimate and we can
send that report we'll make sure we put
that in the chat of how these estimates
were made the the real answer is we
don't know how many people have died we
have to estimate this because there are
challenges in reporting but we know it's
far higher than the the seven million
deaths that have been reported I just
wanted to to clarify also my lasting
memories will not just be of the of the
death it will also be of the incredible
people that I've had the privilege to
work with and continue to work with if
we look at scientific collaboration and
scientific solidarity
um that was incredibly tremendous in the
last three and a half years no matter
what the politics of any country or
anything around the world scientists
really stood up and really worked
together and worked hard to answer those
unknowns to to generate the data for us
to analyze to debate sometimes quite
fiercely but all in an effort to help
people everywhere so for me those are
the the biggest memories that I will
have but I just in my mind can't forget
these things that really Propel me to
get out of bed every day
foreign
I think the thing about crisis
having been through many uh in my life
professional and personal is
that saying it was the best of times it
was the worst of times and I think
that's what you see
during a crisis
it doesn't matter when it happens to you
I was a hostage in Iraq for five months
I saw the best in people
and I saw the worst in people
and
sometimes from the same people so it's
it's uh what is left after a tragedy
after a crisis with the real sense of
confusion
because you're you're happy it's over
but you know the world has changed
the excitement of responding to a crisis
creates its own energy but how do you
sustain that effort after
uh so I I we're not after here we're by
no means are we after
um but it's the little things that stick
with you it's never the big things
received all kinds of awards and many
other things and the most precious thing
I have as an award is a little poster
that
this Maria's son gave to me after a very
particularly bad day a few days in this
pandemic with a lot of the scrutiny that
Dr tedris talks about a lot of the base
discourse and the base attacks is a sad
thing for me to see how our language to
each other and how it engagement to each
other has become so impolite so
attacking so disrespectful and it was a
particularly tough day and I thought I
don't know if we get through another one
and uh Maria's son sent a little poster
to me with a rainbow on it and it said
good job
and that's sitting on my there's a
there's a who thing behind me when I do
my zoom calls and on the top left corner
if those of you who might want to look
more closely you'll often see that
little poster is still there and it just
says good job
I hope we've done a good job it's not
been a perfect job but my abiding
thought of the pandemic is people are
wonderful people have an innate capacity
to survive crisis
we as leaders in whatever field we leave
be it in the front line of the Health
Service being in the front line of
political leadership be in the front
line of innovation we have a duty to
serve the people
and we have more to do if we're going to
serve the people of people properly when
it comes I really hope dearly in my
personal wish is that we can agree in
accord we can agree a new way of doing
business for the future and we can do
that in the next year
okay
um thank you I would like now to give
the floor to another journalist
um Donato Montini from Financial Times
Donato can you hear me
uh good afternoon thanks for taking my
question so what are the practical
consequences of this announcement for
nations in the world could you give us a
bit more detail about that
um and secondly what do you say to those
who will say
this transition came too late I mean
some countries in the world have been
living
as if covert was an emergency for quite
some time now thank you
thank you Donato
um
I could I could start um I'm there
there's a as the DG said um actually
this week we published an updated
strategic preparedness and response plan
which actually outlines what needs to be
done and how we are supporting member
states in this transition the transition
is going to take some time because there
isn't this automatic switch between
everything on and everything off and so
across all of the pillars of responsive
collaborative surveillance Community
protection safe and scalable care access
to countermeasures emergency
coordination we are working with
countries to calibrate this response
going forward we don't want to see
systems shut down we don't want to see
people laid off we don't want to see
Labs close however we have to calibrate
what was done in the crisis point of
this where things were so high and
everything was focused on covid we need
to make sure that countries are dealing
with covet in the context of everything
else in the context of Health
emergencies as well as non-health
emergencies and the crises that they're
facing everything from from energy
crises to floods to war and so all of
the so what we outlined was a two-year
plan and as we said that this decision
of ending the public health emergency is
not a snap decision it isn't something
that we thought of overnight or that the
emergency committee thought during this
debate or this discussion would come up
it was something that's come up over
some time and as an organization we've
been working on this with our member
states in this transition so there are a
lot of practical things countries need
to do in terms of what governments need
to do for surveillance for ensuring safe
clinical care and getting patients into
the clinical care pathway so that they
receive Therapeutics and treatments as
early as possible increasing vaccination
coverage but of course as you know we've
always said it's vaccines and not
vaccines only so investments in
ventilation Investments and making sure
that we have the appropriate way in
which people who need to stay home can
stay home and can continue to work and
still be paid because remember many
people on the front line didn't have the
luxury to stay at home if they were
unwell so there's a lot of things that
need to be put in place and that's why
we say there's a lot more work that
needs to be done so I just wanted to
highlight this strategic preparedness
and response plan it was published on
Wednesday
um it outlines many of the areas of
activities that need to be focused but
we have three objectives in this
strategic plan the first is to reduce
and control the incidence of SARS cov2
variants with increased growth rates and
immune escape with particular focus on
reducing infections and those who are
most at risk and vulnerable populations
secondly to prevent diagnose and treat
covid-19 to reduce mortality morbidity
and long-term sequelae and here we're
also talking about post covid-19
condition
there's a substantial number of people
out there who are suffering from post
covid-19 condition and they need proper
recognition they need proper care they
need throughout the entire duration of
what they are suffering through and the
third objective is for who to support
member states in transitioning from a
crisis response to a sustainable
integrated longer term and strengthened
covid-19 disease management within the
context of their existing programs and
what I mentioned with this earthquake
and these buildings that we're
struggling is we're rebuilding those
buildings we're strengthening and
reinforcing those buildings we're
repopulating the workforce that is there
in supporting people
and that is something that will continue
for years to come
thank you Professor USA
yes I would like to just to say a few
words because the question about
transition to late is of course very
very important and I would like to say
to Mr manchini that the topic was
addressed for the first time that is the
idea of a transition from fake to to
another another status it was addressed
for the first time in January at that
time it was clear that it was necessary
to discuss about the criteria
and discuss about what would be the what
would be the the secure way to to to
give up the fake status
it was again addressed and several
informal meetings were in between to
discuss about these these questions
which are not simple because ihr as you
know is not a very simple text huh the
second thing is that in January 2023 the
question was addressed again but at the
time the situation in in China was
clearly
new and and difficult and it was not
clear clearly not possible at that time
to to go along with the transition and
it was recently addressed during the
last meeting at the moment when when it
appeared to be the right moment for such
a suggestion to the DG
um great I just want to add because I
think it's very important we are never
ever in transition in this organization
we're currently dealing with 54 other
graded Health emergencies around the
world there's never a downtime there's
never a transition there's never
a time when we move from one event to
the other we move between crises all the
time and we haven't been waiting around
uh to to look at a transition we've
created the health emergency
preparedness and response on resilience
architecture has made 10 proposals to
the mem the member states of this
organization on two separate occasions
we're going through member State
consultations on a constant basis uh Dr
Brian is here with us is leading an
initiative called pret an initiative to
bring together all of the measures we
have in place for controlling
respiratory viruses and develop this
scientific Technical and operational
architectures to deal with that she's
also leading a biohub initiative that
rotelos created to create a much better
framework a much better architecture for
sharing specimens and sharing materials
around the world we started the
Universal Health and preparedness review
pilot studies in six countries I've just
come back from Sierra Leone where I went
on behalf of Dr Ted Ross where countries
are now looking much more fundamentally
and at a much higher level at their
Universal Health System items but also
at their pandemic preparedness we've
created the pandemic intelligence Hub in
this has all happened during the
pandemic by the way the pandemic
intelligence Hub in Berlin the Berlin
Hub led by our colleague
which really hopes to fundamentally
address issues around innovation in
epidemic intelligence and epidemic
prediction we've created the global
Health Emergency Corps in collaboration
with the government of Germany the G7
and the bilimananda Gates Foundation
led by Dr Abdi here and and others which
seeks to bring together a lot of
initiatives around the world on Surge
deployments from EMTs to Gorn and many
other things
um so from that perspective
covert has been driving a lot of these
decisions to move forward to innovate to
change the way we do business that's
happening we still need more we need the
Accord we need to have the standing
recommendations we need to have more but
the organization has not been waiting
around to transition I can assure you
out of emergency mode we're constantly
in emergency mode but we need the world
to get into preparedness mode we can't
just keep responding and responding and
responding we have to start preparing
better we have to get the inequities out
of our system we talk about this all the
time we saw people in this pandemic
literally battering for oxygen canisters
on the streets of major cities this is
the 21st century
is that what we want to witness in the
next pandemic
we saw family members physically
fighting to get their loved ones into a
hospital bed
you know we saw people die before they
got to the emergency room because they
were waiting in car parks
that's the reality of our health systems
that's the reality over preparedness
we can talk about all the Technologies
we want but we can't just use technology
to get out of the mess we're in there
are huge inequities in our global system
there are huge inequities in countries
and between countries so we have to
address everything we have to address
technology we have to address our
systems we have to address how we govern
we have to address how we Finance we
have the pandemic fund which is a
fantastic Innovation working with the
World Bank and many other partners and
we've had unprecedented expressions of
interest for that there is a massive
demand out there from public health
Civil Society other organizations at
National level there is a huge demand
to be invested in to build better
systems to build better systems at
Community level
I've said it many times sometimes with
criticism that the single biggest
missing missing commodity of this
pandemic was Trust that tedra spoke to
that
rebuilding trust through building
Platforms in which we can engage our
communities in a way in which they trust
the system they trust each other is
going to be extremely important so
um I don't think uh We've transitioned
late we've been transitioning since the
first day of this pandemic because we
have to move on to a better system thank
you
thank you so much I think we have come
to an end for this press conference I
would like to invite Professor USA if he
has any closing remarks if not a
journalist we sent you the DG opening
remarks already you have also received
the statement of the emergency committee
and all are posted also online other
documents will be sent to you in a
couple of hours so if you have any
follow-up question please don't hesitate
to contact the who
media team and we will be happy to
provide the answers to you thank you for
my colleagues and thank you to
journalists who join this press
conference and now I would like to give
the floor to Dr Pedros for any
for any uh closing remarks
yeah thank you I think Mike had already
said it very very nicely so I don't want
to
spoil what he said so I I would prefer
not to add more but the only thing I
would like to add is
um another cartoon that I got from
Maria's son
the same with
rainbow and saying good job
so getting
um that kind of compliment me from a
child very innocent
and you can at least it makes you feel
really happy
and we were both happy in myself and and
and and and Mike
um and the message there I think for me
was
um
you know the things we should really do
to make the world better for for for the
children for the future
um when I got that card that's what came
to my mind
um and um again I think today's
message is exactly that
of course the emergency is over
but we have started many initiatives to
prepare the world
and we need to continue that that
commitment
and have a real impact a means
do it for our children
his name is Cole for call
so with that thank you so much also to
the members of the media you have been
with us throughout whether it's early
morning or late evening
so thank you so much for your commitment
and for
sending out the words to to the whole
world and thank you look forward of
course to continue working working with
you but
really want to recognize your commitment
and efforts and also express our deep
gratitude
so thank you so much and bye from us
until we see you next time of course the
presser will continue so see you next
time